catherine deneuve nous fait donc le
plaisir d'assister à ce journal pour
parler du dernier métro le dernier métro
c'est un film qui sort demain sur les
écrans il est signée françois truffaut
catherine deneuve en est le personnage
principal je dirais même beaucoup plus
que ça puisque dans ce rôle à mes yeux
elle personnifie la femme la femme de
toutes les époques
la femme qui fait face toutes ses
responsabilités sans pour autant
renoncer à la recherche du bonheur
le dernier métro cela évoque aussi pour
beaucoup d'entre vous les années
d'occupation à paris il ne fallait
surtout pas rater le dernier mais toi
pour le spectacle spectacle
soigneusement surveillées par la
propagande nazie et ses plus fervents
collaborateurs on chassait les juifs
dans les théâtres et dans toute la
culture le chantage était en froid
françois truffaut présente ainsi son
film un film d'amour et d'aventuré qui
exprime notre aversion pour toutes les
formes de racisme et d'intolérance
mais aussi notre affection aux fonde
pour ceux qui ont choisi le métier de
comédien et l'exercent par tous les
temps nous allons voir d'abord un court
extrait du dernier métro vous êtes la
directrice du théâtre catherine deneuve
et gérard depardieu vous annonce qu'il
vous quitte pour entrer dans la
résistance
puis vous m'intimides y ait parfois vous
ne regardiez sévèrement et même avec une
certaine dureté avec une certaine du
retournement
je vous assure je me sentais juger tout
le contraire j'étais troublé pardon oui
c'est vrai j'étais troublé et comme
j'avais l'impression que tout le monde à
les lire sur mon visage
alors j'aime bien aussi c'est ea france
va essayer de les tester
je ne vous ai jamais détesté mais je ne
comprenais pas pourquoi vous étiez
redevenu si distante après avoir
embrassé pas forcément sur la bouche moi
je vous embrasser sur la bouche
oui le soir de la générale pendant le we
do non sûrement pas vous m'avez embrassé
sur la bouche mais pas qu'il ya deux
femmes en moi si justement
alors voilà la question y at il deux
femmes en vous oui je pense qu'il ya de
femmes en moi mais comme vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure j'ai beaucoup
de femmes peut-être un peu plus chez les
actrices et là dans ce film précisément
vous avez 7
cette dualité que j'ai essayé d'évoquer
tout à l'heure en parlant de
responsabilité et aussi de nom ce pas
pour ça à la recherche de l'attirance la
recherche du bonheur oui c'est exact
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui comme tous
les acteurs delà de cette troupe à ce
moment-là essaye de monter un spectacle
qui malgré le plaisir de monter quelque
chose que l'on aime et de participer à
une pièce que l'on aime ne peuvent pas
s'empêcher de subir quand même les
contraintes politiques tellement lourde
et peut-être pour marion steiner le
personnage que j'incarne du film
directrice du théâtre un peu plus lourde
puisqu'elle est directrice de ce théâtre
est provisoirement que ce n'est pas son
métier qu'elle remplace son mari
provisoirement étant juif obligé de se
cacher et
qu'il a donc nommé en son absence
directrice du théâtre on va pas raconter
le film mais vous aimez votre mari mais
vous êtes attirés aussi par un comédien
oui c'est exact j'ai mon mari et je suis
attiré par un comédien et plus je suis
attiré par lui plus j'essaye je crois
veut contrôler cette attirance qui est
difficile disons que c'est une impulsion
que j'essaie de retenir parce que j'ai
une responsabilité plus plus grave et
plus lourde à supporter plus un secret
que je porte pendant longtemps tout seul
ce qui est ce qui rend ce personnage par
moments assez froid est assez distant
puisqu'on somme c'est quelqu'un qui a
quand même peur de se laisser aller et
que ce serait très grave
oui parce que c'est un secret très lourd
et que le partage et représentent un
risque plus grand que de porter tout
seul un des personnages de votre du film
c'est une femme éclate en sanglots tout
à coup au milieu du film est dit mais
c'est pas possible que ce qu'elle peut
être dur avec moi alors est-ce que vous
avez conscience que d'abord est ce que
est ce que vous avez conscience que vous
pouvez apparaître peut-être même au
cinéma comme dans la vie dure alors que
vous ne voulez pas l'être sais pas je
crois que j'aime le ballet tu sais que
je crois que je ne suis pas mais comme
tous les gens qui sont un peu réservé
espace qui est souvent difficilement
compatible avec le métier que je fais
disons que j'ai du mal
j'ai du mal à montrer ce que je voudrais
montrer centre ou le montrer c'est je
suis réservé de nature et par moments ça
peut prendre un visage un peu peut-être
à la limite même antipathique c'est vrai
je suis pas quelqu'un de très expansif
surtout avec les gens que je ne connais
pas bien voilà mai
c'est quelque chose qui vous va au coeur
sain quand on vous dit je suis très dur
avec moi et cette phrase dans le film
parce que pour moi elle me va très bien
et c'est une des phrases les plus durs
son personnage même je crois qu'elle
ajoute elle ne pardonne jamais rien dans
l'histoire du gabon tant que je vous dis
avec une certaine tristesse quand même
parce que c'est pas vraiment mais c'est
une des phrases c'est vrai les plus les
plus durs mais c'est un personnage un
peu dur marion aussi c'est vrai mais
dures comme les gens qui ne peuvent pas
passer trop de temps quand on a beaucoup
de choses à faire
indépendamment de ces raisons
personnelles comme c'est quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup de choses à faire dans la vie
courante dans la journée c'est quelqu'un
on sent qu'il ne peut pas consacrer
beaucoup de temps à chacun d'ailleurs un
moment ils sont pleins en dix ans c'est
injuste et on lui dit elle c'est que
c'est comme ça mais on lui reproche
finalement de ne pas être présente et ne
pas consacrer à chacun du temps parce
que mario est quelqu'un de sincère et
qu'elle ne fait pas semblant donc ne
pouvant pas faire semblant elle préfère
passer sur quelque chose d'autre qui lui
semble plus important et tout est
relatif
vous n'avez pas bien sûr connu cette
période de l'occupation mais je crois
avec truffaut découvert toute une époque
il a remis sur la qualité très documenté
est très documenté ça faisait très
longtemps qu'il avait envie de tourner
un film qui se passerait à ce moment là
moi je me souviens qu'il ya déjà très
longtemps qu'il m'avait parlé d'un
projet et qu'il essayait de trouver le
film qui se prêterait le mieux à cette
époque très particulière qui mélangerait
à la fois la vie le théâtre l'amour
l' aventure et surtout dans ce contexte
répressif de l'occupation à paris oui
puis j'ai dégoupillé qu'après le moment
de la libération
on a beaucoup critiqué les gens qui
avaient continué
certains je crois que c'est toujours
c'est facile pour moi de dire évidemment
quand on trouve toujours des excuses à
aux acteurs mais c'est difficile d'abord
parce que je me dis c'était à traiter
plein vous avez dit que c'était plein
parce que les gens jouaient mais je
crois que c'est facile de dire après on
a continué à jouer lille on continue à
s'amuser sur sans doute ait eu des gens
irresponsables sans doute y ait eu des
gens qui ont été responsables mais je
pense qu'il y en a qui ont joué dans des
conditions plus plus grave que d'autres
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
qui ne se sont pas donné un spectacle
qui n'ont pas distrait les autres qui
ont fait des choses bien plus redoutable
et d'une façon plus anonyme
alors c'est vrai que les gens du
spectacle sont toujours visés vite que
plus rapidement c'est bien de travailler
avec françois truffaut
ah oui c'est très bien dans quel sens
est-ce que c'est très bien mais j'ai
toujours en marche oui oui vous avez
raison mais j'ai toujours remarqué en
lisant des surtout des interviews
d'acteurs étrangers d'actrice plus
particulièrement que c'était un des
metteurs en scène européens qui était le
plus aimé avec lequel les femmes
particulièrement avait le plus envie de
tourner et je partage en connaissance de
cause leurs leur envie que moi j'ai pu
en tous les cas sourire parce que c'est
un oui double chance oui parce que c'est
un metteur en scène qui aime beaucoup
les femmes et que beaucoup de metteurs
en scène croit aimer les femmes et même
les actrices c'est quelqu'un qui aime
avant tout les femmes et je trouve que
ça se sent et jeu on sent bien que les
femmes le sens c'est une chose que les
fameux semble très bien celui de sa
courbe
oui il connaît et il aime les femmes je
trouve que c'est évident en ce sens en
confiance on est on se laisse aller
beaucoup plus facilement avec quelqu'un
qui en a complètement confiance une
dernière question si vous êtes tenté par
le théâtre dit donc je n'ai pas encore
vraiment une envie très grande voix du
théâtre parce qu'il m'est difficile de
d'affronter le public directement
c'est une des choses qui me retient le
plus je trouve que vous n'êtes pas mal à
la télévision est ce que vous n'auriez
pas une dramatique pour nous
et pas pour l'instant mais j'ai eu un
projet qui reprendra peut-être oui merci
capcom aime ça